Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 26th,
uh,
2014 happy Memorial Day.
Happy Memorial Day.
Go to a per rage show,
Yo fucking rich back and go weed a bunch of burgers.
Um,
and then you'll get fucking shit face and say something that you shouldn't have
fucking said.
Maybe hit on your wife's sister.
You get punched in your fucking head.
Anyways,
if you can hear the echo in the room,
they're on back downstairs is the,
the project downstairs inches along.
Um,
you know those,
he listened to podcasts,
you know,
from a year and a half ago,
not even a year and a half,
14 months ago.
I had that fucking water damage.
Um,
I like to think it was a blessing in disguise because the part of the House
upstairs was immaculate and I had just redone that rump,
so that sucked.
But below it was,
it was,
it was a fucking tree fort.
It was shit,
it needs to be fucking replaced anyways.
It's a fucking had enough.
I didn't want to get into it.
And now of course they get under the house.
And what I already knew was because I had somebody do some electrical on my
house before,
he was cleaning up a little bit down there and he's in the crawl space,
which is right underneath my living room.
And I hear him down there every once in a while I was hearing this guy just
going,
what the fuck?
So I knew it wasn't good.
I knew it wasn't good and he told me that there was a lot of shit work down
there and I'm lucky I didn't have a fire.
And then he replaced most of it's so the foreman on this other job,
you know,
some of the stuff that they've taken out,
they actually,
you know,
accidentally disconnected the phone.
You know,
bullshit happens as these guys work on your house.
So,
you know,
he reiterated,
he didn't use the F bomb,
but I could tell by what he was talking about that I had some issues in the
electrical to pot in my house.
So,
um,
you know,
I'm going to get that all taken care of.
Which brings me to my question here,
solar power.
Everybody,
can I take five minutes just to be a fucking hippie man.
Um,
every once in a while I go in and out of my fucking,
you know,
um,
with the team and now and then,
and then I'm against the team,
you know,
kind of like a fuck in,
uh,
like a Randy Moss,
you know,
you're coming to town,
you got your mind right.
And after about a season and a half,
you start acting like a fucking maniac.
That's how I feel when I look at,
uh,
whatever the fuck and explore.
I'm really trying to avoid the expression,
the powers that be,
but,
um,
I dunno,
I can't help it every time when I land in Los Angeles and I look out at the
basin as they call it,
I'm from the San Gabriel mountains all the way south of that,
which is fucking La and greater la,
all of that,
just what an absolute clusterfuck it is.
And um,
what happens when the shit hits the fan?
So I'm thinking about getting some solar panels and I know all you rednecks out
there saying the obvious thing,
right?
Fuck good.
Just solar pane.
I'm going to do,
if he ain't got a gun,
what are you going to keep the guy warm that fucking shoot you in the head.
Steels you previsions I understand.
They're fucking bearded.
Wonder.
All right,
I get it.
But one step at a time.
One step at a fucking time.
First thing I want to do,
I want to get,
it was ridiculous.
I live in a fucking desert,
the house,
big sin,
the sun and I'm,
I still have,
I don't have solar power.
It's the dumbest shit ever.
So,
uh,
I'm going to look into it and I want,
I want to know is,
is,
you know,
is it two types of solar power?
There's one where you're still on the grid and then there's one where you're off
the grid.
I like off the grid and if anybody's listening to my podcast,
if you're off the grid,
like what happens?
Did they like get,
do they get mad at you?
I mean,
how do they know?
Because all of a sudden your bill goes down.
Does that like set off a light,
you know,
and underneath the mountain that all those Illuminati guys live in and then
somebody pulls up to your house.
Say,
I noticed you,
I haven't been making any toasts lately.
And uh,
you know what's going on here?
Okay.
How come you're not,
you're not watching TV.
What are you reading books in their fucking eaten apples off the tree.
How come you're not using any electrical,
uh,
tricity there?
Does that happen?
Is it,
it's not illegal to be off the grid.
They just sort of fucking a,
okay.
Do they bully you at all?
Like,
just let me know what I'm in for.
All right.
Because what I would love to do is it continue spending my legal tender that
really has nothing behind it other than the faith of every freckled face cut
over here.
Um,
I would really love to continue existing in this,
but I would like to have the backup that if the shit does hit the fan
okay.
Before I'm overrun by a mob,
you know,
because mine's the only light on the top of the hill.
See,
that's ice.
Do a bit about that.
That's the thing,
like if you actually have,
if you're off the grid,
all right?
And everything just goes fucking haywire.
You immediately,
you've got to cut your lights out quick.
Okay?
Because the first thing when everybody loses power,
they stand that go,
oh,
you gotta be fucking shitting me.
I was watching two broke girls,
right?
That's the first thing
you flipped the switches is it then,
then you know within 30 seconds you're like,
is it just our house?
And you look out the window.
So you basically,
you have 30 fucking seconds to cut all your lights off.
Tell your wife does shut the fuck up and get downstairs and that little corner
room.
All right.
And you put your hand on a shoulder.
Okay?
Normally you don't hurt him,
but you're not affectionate.
You place your hand on her shoulder.
So she knows that some pertinent fucking information is on the way.
And you say,
honey,
we're the only ones left are the other ones that look at me.
Stop crying.
We're the only one.
We're the only ones left with power.
And I need you to hold it together.
Cry It out.
Now I want you to cry every ounce of bitch you have in you,
out of you and this corner in this house,
okay?
And when you come upstairs,
I want you to sit here and act like we do not have power.
Okay?
So when the Sullivan's come across the fucking street and see if we don't have
power,
why did their fucking faces
ani?
Forget about the cell.
They're not going to make you understand.
Yeah.
I don't want that to happen.
I don't want that to happen to anybody,
but I don't want to be the Sullivan.
You know what I mean?
I want a shot.
Just give me a fucking shot.
That's all I need.
I just need some solar panels and a fucking helicopter and I will get the fuck
outta here.
That's what you need.
You fucking 80 switch it guns,
Huh?
What are you Schwartzenegger how long is that gonna last?
Um,
anyways,
so I'm thinking about it.
Does anybody,
is anybody live in the La area?
Does anybody have solar panels anywhere in the fucking world?
Can you recommend,
are there two different kinds?
Because I actually looked up solar panels off the grid and uh,
I came to this place a blue Pacific solar,
it says off grid packages.
Um,
then there's another one that just says get solar power,
Sun power off grid systems.
Off Grid System.
Backwoods solar electric systems.
Yeah,
I kind of stole that Shit.
Well,
what we're gonna do is we're going to bring it in and we'll just run it over the
outhouse.
Well,
what
Cabana?
W what's that?
A cigar.
I'm
sorry,
I'm going to stupid fucking load this week.
MMM.
Yeah.
Oh,
then there's one for Australia.
I don't mind paying the grid,
but I would like to have,
if the grid fails to have the then off the grid switch.
How about that?
Can we just have that,
those of you who've been on the Internet this week,
you know the direction that I'm working in.
Oh yes.
Should do the stop being modest.
Do you know the direction I'm going?
And I'm talking about solar fucking Rhodes.
Has anybody seen this,
this youtube video?
It's fucking amazing if,
if what they're saying is true about these solar roads.
Um,
and I apologize for the narrator.
I get what he's doing.
He's trying to keep it interesting,
but he kept it interesting too long and then he brings it down to an interlude,
which should have come a minute earlier and then he goes back to scream.
And so it's a little bit annoying,
but,
uh,
just try to listen to the information and then try not to get sucked into a
George Bush Obama debate because,
uh,
I dunno,
I dunno if these things,
what the fuck do I know?
Right?
But it just basically saying,
if we replaced all our roads with these solar fucking things that literally
look,
makes it look like Lego land and it's all lit up and there'd be sensors to let
you know,
a deer's going around the corner and then it would just light up in the turn a,
there's a fucking deer around the corner,
you know,
enjoy your barley pancakes or whatever.
Right?
Some fucking full on Hippie Shit.
And that basically the amount of energy that it would create would be three
times what this country even needed,
which immediately we can just leave the Middle East.
Right?
We don't have to be over there pissing them off by getting in the middle of
their bullshit.
All right.
We don't have to deal with oil and oil money is what funds the terrorist as far
as my limited reading goes.
Right?
The,
the,
the families over there that,
fuck,
hang on,
she's scratching.
I just gave you a bath.
What's wrong?
Oh,
um,
anyways,
uh,
yeah,
like the fucking the,
the oil people over the people who make all the money over there,
they then donate to mosques.
And then in the mosque,
they fucking,
you know,
kind of fucking a,
send it over to these fucking people over here.
That ended up coming back at US shooting shit at us as far as you know,
like I said,
I don't know shit.
Cleo,
would you stop fucking,
you're going to have to go to the other room here.
Come here buddy.
What's up?
Sweden?
We went on a nice hike today,
didn't we?
Huh?
If we good.
All right,
get out of here.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
yeah,
and then that whole fucking thing is just null and void.
We have all this extra power actually.
Did we create a bunch of jobs?
The only thing I don't know is the way it looks.
It doesn't seem like it's a smooth ride.
It just seems like the whole time he'd be going like over these fucking things.
I have no idea,
but just check it out and I swear to God,
because this is something that I don't know if it,
if it is,
if it does work,
if it does fucking work,
it could benefit everybody.
Conservatives,
liberals,
independence,
everyone who wouldn't benefit from all of this energy,
all that.
Right?
The people in power.
Oh,
how could I forget that?
That's right.
How do you think that they're going to derail this if this actually becomes a
movement,
how will they somehow tie in terrorism?
Nine 11 liberals fucking right wing conservatives and just get the,
the pot fucking stern so everybody's screaming and yelling.
It was good.
It will be for heaven,
a glimpse batches and the babies will starve.
They're going to do all of that shit.
Um,
the only way this thing gets off the ground,
if it works,
is if people don't get sucked into those arguments and we all become one and we
all pick up a hatchet and we start marching towards the bankers.
Gated communities.
Okay?
Because the asphalt streets,
we'll have to run red with blue blood money before something wonderful like this
will ever fucking happen because you are fucking with,
okay.
A century and a half of cashflow going to a small amount of people.
That's what you fucking with.
And when you're fucking with something like that,
that level of money,
basically the money that gives the dollar power,
like the only thing gives the u s dollar powers that oil barrels of oil are
still measured in US dollars.
Other than that,
it's a fucking shit show.
So these guys are the guys behind all of that.
It's them in the fucking bankers and that's it.
All right.
The insurance companies like the Ted Kennedy or that fucking family.
All right,
but fucking Bobby and Jack.
All right.
Actually the banks have fucking Joe Kennedy.
They'll shut up with the Kennedy Shit.
All right.
So anyways,
that's my thing.
Like this is a great fucking idea.
If it works,
if it works,
it's a fucking great idea.
Even if you just did a few roads,
if he just did a few of them,
each state just did like their main highway or whatever.
If you just did that,
I can't imagine the amount of of money it would save and on the less than a man
who was in the possibilities of it are incredible.
I don't know if it works,
but it is fucking incredible.
But the sad thing is,
um,
the fact that whenever new stuff like this comes up,
it all just turns into a Obama,
Bush,
Republican,
Democrat,
blah,
blah.
And everybody's just yelling at each other and then it just fucking goes away.
And then everybody turns on sports.
And that's what happens.
So that you go,
this is all off the grid,
Billy,
15 minutes of crazy talk.
But that makes sense to me.
Makes sense to me,
man.
Fuck,
you know,
we get
so fucking weird,
bro.
All them liberals out there in Hollywood,
right?
And I get to tell you,
I'm not,
I'm,
I'm not just making fun of stereotypical southern guy.
All right,
because I haven't lived out here in Hollywood.
These people are out of their fucking mind state there.
Fox News to the left,
they're out of their fucking minds.
Does such fucking hypocrites where it's just like,
you can say the most,
uh,
I guess racist isn't the word.
Cause you can make fun of white people,
rich,
white people.
You,
you can basically,
you can be a,
you can use the exact fucking thing that they don't like seeing used on poor
people against rich people,
and they fucking love it.
You know,
you can suggest that people from the south are all fucking this sisters and
they're slapping their knees and they're doing the wave in the crowd.
All right?
But if you suggest any homeless guy needs to get off his fucking ass,
stop boozing and get a fucking job,
then you're the devil.
So,
I mean,
I don't know.
Does that make any sense?
Well,
it shouldn't.
Isn't that why you listen to this podcast?
You cunts.
Alrighty.
Then let's,
uh,
let's do a little bit of advertisements.
I'd like to add or any solar people want to advertise in this fucking podcast.
How much does it cost?
All right.
He voice everybody.
He voice a voice.
Why don't you get this shit?
Um,
he voice everyone.
You're a business owner,
but automated phone systems and secretaries are secretaries are not in your
budget,
Jess,
yet.
And juggling incoming calls can make you seem like you're not even professional.
Well,
here's something that will dramatically affect your ability to make more money
in 2014 what is it?
It's easy boys.
Everybody,
whether you're a business of one or 100 eve voice will help you manage all of
your incoming calls with a toll free number.
Dial by name,
directory,
and call routing tools.
Your business will sound like 1 million bucks.
Can't take a call,
no problem.
Eve Voice.
We'll transcribe that voicemail and email it right to you so you'll never be
caught off guard again and with he voice,
you can try it before you buy it over there.
Right now,
just from my listeners,
they're only advertise in here.
Have you buddy?
This is exclusive.
You can get a 60 day.
What the hell is with these types of sweet a 60 day trial of IIE voice?
Absolutely free.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the Promo Code Bill B I l l for the people
who went to public schools.
Do that at checkout.
Take charge of your business and make more money in 2014 go to [inaudible] dot
com and enter in bill at checkout for your 60 day free trial.
That's a voice Promo Code Bill.
Okay.
Oh here they are.
Our old friends,
dollar shave club,
everybody.
There are so many things that piss me off.
Not having solar robes.
The fact that I rented a Chevy Impala this week cause my truck's getting fixed
and it's supposed to be the flagship one with the v eight that when I'm on the
slightest little bill at bit of a hill and I go to put it in reverse,
it rolls forward a little bit like some hunk of crap from the 70s come on Chevy.
You can do better than that.
Those are a few things that piss me off and you know what else pisses me off?
Oh,
he's coming around again.
Everybody pay way too much to shave.
My freckled face is definitely up there.
Ah,
nothing feels better than shaving with the fresh new blade.
Everybody but new razors are so ridiculously expensive that you can't afford a
change your blade more than once every six months.
So you end up scalp and you're faced with an old blade.
Come on,
we've all been there.
Dollar Shave,
you change your blade as much as you change.
You've got to buy new deodorant.
That's basically the deal unless you have with Donald Trump,
you know,
and then you pretend you have money for blades.
You drive around your dumb helicopter with your name on the back.
Trump dollar shave club delivers top quality raises for a few bucks a month.
Dollar Shave Club members always shave with a fresh blade because they get a
fresh pack in the mail every month.
Talk candidly about your experiences with the program.
What you just explained it.
All right.
I won't tell me what to do.
Dollar Shave Club.
I'll talk candidly when I feel like it.
They've got lots of other great products like the classic Dr Cabbies,
Evie Shave,
he's he shaved and doctor [inaudible] Post Shave,
post shave.
That sounds very sexual.
POSTDOC to carvings poised.
Codal coital.
Sorry.
Join the hundreds of thousands of guys who've upgraded to the smarter way to
shave,
shave time,
shave money,
join dollar shave club.com/barb you are support this podcast and a great company
by going to dollar shave club.com/bird dollar shave club.com/bar.
That is a great company.
You know,
for years I used to sit there going,
why the fuck does it cost so much?
God Damn money,
you know?
But all I did was talk about it.
That's son of a bitch.
Went out and did it.
Now he's the millionaire.
Oh Jesus.
All right,
let's talk sports here.
let's start with the NBA.
Something I never watch,
but you know,
it's the conference finals.
I've had some downtime.
So basically what I've been doing is,
um,
it's the,
the hockey conference finals and the BNB conference finals.
So what I do is I take the NBA game as I watch the NHL game live.
And then the following morning I watch the NBA game and I got to tell you,
it's been a slice of heaven.
It's been a slice of heaven.
Um,
and you know what?
I got back into NBA hoop and I got back into the simplicity and the beauty of
just coming out there with a ball,
trying to put it through a heel.
Hope it's a fucking pure game.
It is a wonderful game.
If those fucking reps we just got with it,
they would just relax.
Classic example,
I don't even know who won this game yet and I'm going to go watch it as I
upload.
I've only watched the first quarter of the last Okc,
uh,
San Antonio Spurs game.
All right?
Now as far as I understand,
the job of the referee is to keep the game under control,
keep the game under control and let the players decide who's going to win the
fucking game.
All right?
I watched the first quarter of the game.
All right.
Okay.
So He's already in trouble cause that surge a Baka guys that how you say his
name,
the big man.
His heart.
All right,
so he's on the elliptical.
So they got Kendrick Perkins in there and what is the fucking ref do?
Gives him three fucking bowls,
two different bullshit fucking calls.
And puts the guy in the bench.
They already got one guy in the elliptical,
you know,
they need Kendrick Parkins and you give them two bolts to guide fucking three
files in the first quarter.
The last two,
I swear to God,
he was standing there scratching his ass and they gave him a file.
Then I watched him with the,
who's,
who's the guy there?
Who,
who,
you know,
uh,
what the fuck's his name?
That point guard who sometimes turns into an eight year old,
uh,
begins with a w why do I keep thinking with their spine?
Because I'm old.
You know what I'm talking about?
That fucking guy,
right?
Manou [inaudible],
whatever his name is,
that Guy Refuses to shave his fucking head steals the ball from him.
All right,
so you see the fucking guy,
he turns into the eight year old,
he runs right up and tries to slap it away from,
takes a file and he,
you know,
when he's sitting there,
he doesn't even look at the ref.
He says something like,
that's fucking bullshit.
And the ref is standing there staring at them.
How do I know we staring at them?
Because even the guy announcing the game,
Reggie Miller,
I think it was was going that ref should have fucking given them the file and
walked away.
He stands there.
Not only stands,
it stands there staring at him,
waiting from this.
Say something.
Now I know,
I know this guy probably has a fucking reputation for doing that,
but it's just like that.
It's a complete fucking abuse of power and these guys,
their job is to to keep the game under control,
not control the pace of the game.
And that's what I fucking hate about the NBA.
All right there.
Okay there.
Sorry.
I got my fucking Tampon mentality this week,
but it's the fucking thing that I cannot stand about the NBA,
that goddamn officiating,
whether it's fixed or not,
I don't fucking know.
But those guys,
they need to relax.
Clear.
What is the problem?
I just gave you a bath.
I wrenched your good
fucking thing.
I feel,
you know,
it's such a ridiculous level how much I love that dog.
Even know what the thing that drives me nuts drives me nuts.
Um,
anyways,
but it's still great.
What a great series.
Uh,
even at woke,
Casey is down at this point,
two games than,
I don't know if it's three at this point.
It's just,
I dunno,
Spurs are fun to watch.
Okay.
See,
he's fun to watch and uh,
you know,
as much,
I imagine pacer fans are frustrated with their team,
you know,
they just don't know how to win yet.
They,
they,
you know what they liked.
They liked the little brother that's big enough at this point to finally win a
fight against his older brother.
But the,
the,
the older brother has a psychological advantage because he's been kicking their
ass.
They're entire fucking life,
you know,
up,
hang on,
she's scratching again.
Um,
that's their problem.
You know,
I dunno.
Jason Law had knows the game better than me.
He also says that coach stinks and Larry Bird should literally walked down and
fire the guy
during the game and just take over because he's getting brutally out coached.
I have no idea.
I'm actually happy that I'm watching the NBA again.
Again,
I just wish these fucking rests would just put their fucking whistles away
or at least just be consistent.
I they had the fucking worst.
And I know when every sport you can have bad officiating and he can have shit
calls,
but like the NBA is,
is at the top of the fucking list.
Okay.
Cause it goes beyond bad calls that go because what their power,
they can put guys on the bench.
It's just fucking drives me nuts.
Relax bill.
Okay,
I will.
Um,
let's talk to some hockey here.
How about those fucking ray?
I have never,
I can't,
I did the last time I was just wrong about somebody.
The,
the,
the fucking patriots traded bloop drew Bledsoe to the buffalo bills.
And I was like,
that guy's going to come back to harness.
And I forgot that the poor bastard was playing for the fucking bills and it
isn't his fault where I thought they were going to come back and kill us.
Um,
and I also thought that Tom Brady got lucky as first year.
That's what I thought.
See,
so I don't know shit.
And how's that?
Just have not been believing in the ranges in here.
They are one game away.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the New York's fucking rangers who tortured their fans every fucking year except
1994.
Since 1940.
They've been torturing those motherfuckers.
They are one game away from going to the Stanley Cup finals.
Um,
it's been a great,
so what have fucking game that was and it could easily be two,
two,
um,
just an incredible game yesterday.
And um,
I really enjoyed,
uh,
I've really been enjoying that series because I know the Canadians aren't going
to quit.
I think they're going to win the next one.
And uh,
then there'll be games six.
It's gonna fuck and you know,
add pressure to the ranges.
Like fuck,
we can't lose this one.
Cause it was like we don't want to game seven with these guys.
I'm basically praying foot boat series,
both the king's hawks and the a rangers,
Canadians to go seven games.
Same thing with the basketball,
even though it doesn't look like it's going to.
Yeah.
MMM.
I want more hockey,
more hoop.
Okay.
To bridge the gap between the end of those series.
And the beginning of NFL football.
But then again,
why am I shitting on the national pastime?
Why don't I just fucking embrace that too?
That's what I should do.
I don't fucking know.
But um,
and then then the hawks king series,
it's just been fucking ridiculous.
MMM.
The hawks came out,
game won it.
They just look like what everybody thought they were.
Okay.
Just as I guess date,
if they wanted to share,
they are considered a dynasty.
Don't you know what's funny is the level,
the amount of teams and how hard it is to win a championship has increased over
the years.
That when I was a kid,
you had to win three in a row to be a dynasty.
And then three and four years,
like they gave it to the Patriots where we won one Buccaneers,
one.
And then we won.
We won,
we went three and four years and they said that was a dynasty.
And now talkie Chicago one,
2010,
2013 and then if they win again this year,
they were going to give them a dynasty.
Um,
whatever you want to call it,
it's fucking impressive what they're doing because they lose guys every year.
But there's somehow able to,
to not,
um,
dip and quality like the way we did.
You know,
we made some moves,
gathered a Tyler Sagan and some of those guys got a little bit older,
little little more inexperienced at the same time.
And I think that hurt us in the end,
um,
with the hawks are doing amazing,
but then the fucking kings come roaring back.
Was it six to to just kick their ass and then the hawks come back.
Game three I think.
And it is just,
that was just like a heavyweight battle.
Them just going at it and uh,
I can't,
can't wait.
If you listen to this podcast before game tonight,
jump on the fucking bandwagon.
If you just want to watch hockey at its highest level,
watch the king's Hawk serious.
It's fucking insane.
I'm actually tried to get tickets for tonight.
Didn't work out.
I don't think it's gonna work out.
Called up my connection and it ain't fucking happening there.
But,
uh,
I'm definitely going to be watching that series dry.
Do you guys know I'm one day away from 40 days without a drop of booze?
Fucking brutal.
You know,
I swear to God,
if I went to an AA meeting right now and they tried to give me one of those
chips,
I'd throw it at him,
you know,
fucking throw it out.
I'm just start screaming.
I'm not enjoying this.
MMM.
I liked that.
I've lost some weight,
but uh,
I'm getting ready to do a special everybody and tickets are on sale.
If you want to be at the live taping of my next special so you can say to your
loved ones,
I was there when that hour of filth was recorded.
Um,
I'll,
we'll have the link up.
Tickets are going fast.
Thank God.
I'm going to be at the Tabernacle in,
um,
okay.
Atlanta,
Georgia and I can't wait to come back.
It's one of my favorite theaters and uh,
I'm really hoping,
um,
I dunno,
I'm nervous about this one,
man.
I got to try to top my last one,
which is the only thing you can really do is just try to top your last one.
And um,
I dunno.
Yeah,
I got to get myself in the mindset.
I'm not in the mindset yet.
That mindset has to be where you don't give a fuck,
but you do and you're having fun in your Improv.
And like I would during a normal show,
which,
so I basically have to block out.
That's the thing,
you block out that the cameras are there and then you also don't start thinking
like,
oh fuck,
I missed a tag.
Who gives a fuck?
No,
we're just going to know,
okay,
you're not documenting the joke,
your documentary thing,
like that night's performance of the joke and that's the way it came up.
I want you to do that.
Then you can fucking free yourself up.
So,
um,
yeah.
What am I just want to fucking do it already.
I was supposed to be doing it the first week and I was going to do it in San
Francisco,
but uh,
the fucking unions up there,
Jesus Christ fucking beat.
I'm pro unit beaten the shit out of me.
Okay.
You got to fucking hire 15 guys.
Do a bring a mic,
stand out on the fucking stage.
And I'm like,
well fuck this place.
Don't go cross the street.
Yeah,
it's going to be 16 guys.
All right.
You know what all the leaves are Brown.
Fuck this town.
I went to Atlanta.
I'm definitely coming back now.
I'm just going to do,
I'm just going to do San Francisco.
I'm just not going to fucking film there.
It's unreal.
You know,
bad.
I wanted to,
I want it to what those wacky unions.
Um,
anyways,
what else am I talking about here?
Um,
Jesus Christ and I did,
I do all my topics already in my already into the questions.
While I am 30 minutes in,
I'm,
I'm actually supposed to be going to a,
a to a Blab Acu.
Um,
I had the guy actually all my buddies over on,
uh,
on Saturday and we watched game three of the king's game.
Dude was fucking great and um,
okay.
Grilled up some steaks.
I'm one of those guys too.
I don't give a fuck.
I'll let somebody,
somebody like,
man,
let me grill those up.
Go ahead and grill them up.
I don't give a fuck.
You know,
I was upstairs making the fucking garlic mashed potatoes like a fucking lady.
I don't care.
I really don't give a fuck.
I know that really fucks with my man card that I have another guy come over here
and jump on my grill.
I don't give a shit.
I really don't.
I just want to make sure people have drinks.
You know,
I'm up here wearing my apron.
I'm really in touch with my feminine side.
When I turn on my grill loggerheads cooked on it.
Now court mccown fucking made the stakes on it.
You don't sound like I don't cook on it,
but I just thought,
I don't know.
The stakes looks so good.
I actually got some anxiety is like,
I don't want to fuck these up court through money handled them and I up to,
I was up here and I made potatoes
a what?
A pussy.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
I hope my dad doesn't listen to this.
Um,
I got a couple of the frozen ones up there.
I'll throw mud.
Oh,
make them for me and my wife.
Ah,
what a pussy.
Anyways,
uh,
sorry.
This just making me fucking laugh.
I really am dude.
I'm either a fucking type a Alpha male or I'm wearing an apron.
I really am a Gemini.
It all depends on the situation.
I will either not take an ounce of shit.
Oh,
I will let you roll.
Right the fuck over me as I hand you my wallet.
It all depends on the situation.
Um,
yeah,
Bill,
it's called being a schizophrenia.
I go fuck yourself.
All right.
The big thing in my life is,
uh,
yesterday I went out and I bought a new snare drum and I can't wait cause I
bought this old Ludwig Kit and I know I've been straightening a long time.
It'd be doing these drum coverage,
but I'm getting close.
I got my drum kit and uh,
I bought an early seventies green spot.
Go.
I'll fucking bottom sizes.
So now Mike and they,
of course,
they never come with the snare.
I don't know what happens with the snare.
People just want to keep the fucking snare and they break up the kit.
So I went out,
you know,
I was looking on the Internet trying to find a fucking 1971 Ludwig six and a
half by 14 fucking snare.
And I just can't find,
I was just like,
you know what,
why don't you just go buy a new one and then you know,
one comes along and you have whatever you add it to the fucking kid who gives a
shit.
But,
uh,
I bought it.
And odd as it sounds sweet,
it's not sweet.
And I've been practicing a lot.
I've been on the practice pad big time.
And what I learned yesterday when I got behind the kit is the practice pad is
not a drum kit.
And I sounded like shit.
And then what was funny was I went over to go buy a snare drum afterwards and
when they were trying to see if they had a hard shell case for it,
I was uh,
I got down,
I sat on one of those,
The v drums,
the electronic kits and um,
those things sound so unbelievable.
Like,
I was joking with a buddy.
Now,
Dean del Ray from the,
uh,
let there be talk podcasts and the all things comedy network,
you know,
we went over there together and uh,
I was joking with the most,
with those electronic drums,
like you sit behind a real kit,
you're like,
oh my God,
I suck.
Thank God nobody's here to listen to this.
You get behind the electronic kits and you just like,
how come I'm not in a band?
I'm fucking awesome.
Like they sound so unbelievable and they're so forgiving.
Um,
I sat down on those,
uh,
those v drums up tight right now.
If you ever wanted to play drums and you're worried about how loud they're going
to be and he just want to have fun,
you got to get,
get the Fucking v drums.
And this is not a commercial,
just get the,
this is just me saying this,
just get the Fucking v drums because you can actually control the volume of
them.
You can play in with headphones,
you can be downstairs,
your wife can't even hear it.
Whatever your roommates or whatever.
And if you live in an apartment,
all you do is you go out and you get,
um,
you know,
those little,
I think I've talked about this before,
you know those things,
those overly protective parents get in the playroom,
those interlocking like little rubber,
a spongy floor thing.
So if a kid falls down,
he doesn't hurt himself.
You just get those and you get two layers of it and you put it underneath the
kit and then you go downstairs.
Do you downstairs neighbor and you say,
Hey,
my name's so-and-so.
This is my phone number.
All right,
if I'm ever playing in,
in your at home,
call me up and I will stop immediately.
Anybody has a problem with that?
There are a cunt and then he should play at two in the morning.
All right,
there you go.
So that's what's going on in my life.
Let me read the last of the advertising here and we'll get into your questions
there.
Oh,
by the way,
the all things comedy.
Um,
once a month we do a show,
we do a standup show and uh,
the little money that we make goes to help paying the rent at our studio.
We do it at the bootleg theater tomorrow night.
Listen to this fucking lineup.
All right,
we got,
we got David Kempner,
David Kempner from uh,
anchorman.
We got Dana Gould,
Dana Gold,
one of the greatest standup comics ever.
That's what we got.
We got Al Madrigal and we got the,
we got the muscle from the rose bowl tailgate legend Joe Barton.
Nick,
that's just for,
we got Tom Papa Tom Pop.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a killer line.
There's not a better fucking show in Los Angeles tomorrow night.
You got to go out,
you got to go check it out,
help support the all things comedy network.
Um,
I,
I would appreciate it as what everybody else over here at all things.
Comedy.
All right.
Hulu plus everybody.
Hulu plus you've probably tried Hulu on your computer.
Hulu plus is so much more with Hulu plus you can watch current season episodes
of your favorite shows like modern family,
the daily show and scandal.
And watch every episode of shows like Nashville,
my wife loves that show lost and doctor who you get ad free movies and kid show
to kids shows too.
Sorry.
Now more than ever,
there is so much to watch.
Take total control with Hulu plus the stream these shows and thousands more as
much as you want,
wherever you want.
Hulu plus works on your computer,
smartphone or smart TV,
Roku,
apple TV,
Xbox,
playstation.
Pretty much any streaming device you already own.
You can even watch on your eye and your phone or your iPad while on the train at
work,
at the dentist or in the bathroom.
You can even block off a data bent to binge.
Dude,
I got to start doing this man.
The way I'm on the road.
This is fucking great.
It's fucking great man.
I love it.
You'll also get access to originals,
all two originals that you can get anywhere else.
Check out the new show.
Deadbeat a comedy about a pot smoking guy who talks to ghost binge on all 10
episodes starting April 9th,
uh,
for only seven 99 a month.
You get your shows anytime,
anywhere.
That's like a quarter a day.
Come on people right now.
Sign up at Hulu plus.com/bill or click on the banner on my website and get two
weeks full access,
completely free.
That's a whole extra week more with this special offer when you sign up at Hulu
plus.com/bill so get with it and start streaming TV now with Hulu plus and last
mercifully the last reader this week.
Sorry guys,
I'm extra bed this week.
A legal zoom.
Everyone America was built by innovators and dreamers.
Jesus.
That's a rosy picture.
Innovators,
dreamers and homicidal maniacs.
Uh,
people like Thomas Edison,
all I want a swell guy.
He was and then re Ford.
Oh yeah.
That anti-semite laid the foundations for our country.
I don't know if he was,
I don't know if how confusing Henry Ford,
Walt Disney,
uh,
these days,
it's the,
if you know what,
that's not even their fault.
It's just because of when they were born that was acceptable.
Um,
these days it's the inventors and the entrepreneurs all around us like you that
keep our country running by fueling the job market and the economy.
This month,
legal zoom celebrates innovation by helping you launch your dream.
Apply for a patent to secure your invention.
Exactly.
This is exactly if you're out there inventing stuff,
you need legal zoom to get a patent before those corporate.
You know what's,
steal it from you.
All right?
And if they want to buy your idea,
don't ever give them ownership of it ever.
You never give up ownership.
All right?
I was kidding who.
If you don't give him part ownership,
they'll just steal it from you and be like,
what?
Go ahead and sue us.
I'm telling you people we need to march up that solar road.
Sorry.
Apply for a patent.
Secure your invention.
Register your trademark to protect your products and services.
Incorporate or form an LLC and launch your business.
This is how you deal with people.
This is how you protect yourself.
Visit Legal zoom.com and use the discount code bur bur they'll provide the
personal attention you need and help take care of all the details they've helped
over 1 million businesses get started and get started,
right,
and they received an a plus from the better business bureau.
These are the guys,
everybody celebrate innovations with legal zoom today and get a special price on
trademark,
copyright or provisional patent applications by using the discount code bur bur
a checkout.
Once again,
legal zoom provides legal help through independent attorneys and self help,
but they are not a law firm.
legalzoom.com discount code burr.
That's the way you set it up.
Everybody,
if you've got a great idea you to protect yourself from day one because they
will try and steal it from you.
All right?
Every business is the same.
My business is no difference.
All right?
You write the show,
you bring it to them.
We love it,
we own it.
And then we're going to pay you this.
And then in during residuals that gets cut in half and it gets cut in half
again.
And then one day we're sending you checks for 6 cents and we're still collecting
millions.
And then if you audit us,
we're going to label you as difficult.
That's how it works.
Everybody.
So go to legal zoom.
All right.
Okay,
here we go.
Um,
what does this say?
Good meal.
But email is also mentioned the Monday morning podcast or yeah,
the Monday morning podcast.
We have our own Twitter account.
Finally,
if you'd like to follow the EMM podcast and get the links for all the videos and
all this stuff that I talk about,
follow us here at the [inaudible] podcasts.
Um,
our Twitter handle is at the MMP,
a podcast at the MM podcasts and MMP is all capitalized.
All right.
Okay,
here we go.
First one Bruins.
Bill.
Why didn't the Bruins just take out Kerry price range have figured this out in
game one.
Um,
ah,
come on man.
You don't want to do that shit,
you know,
deliberately hurt somebody.
Um,
but I will say that I don't think Kerry price is quite as good as people say is
if you go up top,
you got the guy.
Unless you miss it every fucking time.
The way we did,
we really,
uh,
we really screwed the fucking pooch.
But um,
I definitely think he's one of the elite goalies in the league,
but I wouldn't,
I think I'd say the king's my quickest,
the best.
Is it Mike Quick on my,
is that the fucking guy from the eagles?
I'm so fucking old.
I just combined generations of people.
I got to look this up now out.
Jonathan quick.
Mike quick.
Yeah.
My quick play for the eagles.
I knew that didn't sound right.
I've watched people,
I've watched all three fucking games and they've said Johnathan quick a zillion
times and I still sit my quick,
I might fucking brain stop retaining information somewhere around the late
eighties,
early nineties.
My apologies that Johnathan quick.
I think he's the best I'll tell you,
I don't think is his fucking good as his numb is,
numbers is a,
the Blackhawks Crawford.
I just think he has an incredible group of people in front of them and uh,
he plays with the lead a lot so people can get back on deep.
But I've noticed,
you know,
all of a sudden they start chasing it a little bit.
They got to take the chances.
I'll tell you that five holes looking pretty tasty.
The,
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
whatever.
Uh,
I gotta be honest with you.
If we took out Kerry price,
I mean,
I don't think it would've made a difference to Canadians.
They were just better than us and they're moving in the right direction and I
hope that we do so.
Uh,
there you go.
All right.
Dilemma.
The dilemma here for the week.
Bill,
I haven't heard you read a dilemma in a while.
Here's one.
Would you rather fight three rabid dogs with the thirst for blood with a sword?
Oh yeah.
I can fucking take them out
or take your chances with one bullet and a bear coming at you from 100 yards
away.
Keep in mind the dogs can kill you and that it can take more than one bullet to
kill a bear.
Absolute fucking lutely.
I know that.
Hey,
I don't know that I've just watched enough youtube videos.
Um,
I saw,
I actually saw youtube videos wanting once you one of those fail when videos and
why do they always have to put a picture of some hot chick bending over and then
she's never in it.
It's like,
I'm going to watch it anyways.
What are you getting my hopes up for watching people fail and succeed is
compelling.
It's compelling enough.
You don't have to put some chick with the fucking,
you know,
the Kini covered clamp fucking winking at me in the beginning of it,
and then it's not there.
It's false advertising.
You cuts.
You know what I'm doing is I'm starting to just click on the ones that don't
have that
fucking pussies stand on.
The merit of the footage is stole.
But anyways,
I was watching one of those fail when videos and uh,
to see this guy,
he was hunting wild boar and he fucking shoots at the thing.
He misses in the fucking thing,
turns around and just starts running at him.
He misses again and then he fucking ran away.
Dude,
you just got your best.
What are you going to outrun?
A fucking wild boar.
You're nuts.
Well,
she had trucks right there.
I'm telling you,
you got to just stand there.
If I had to shoot a fucking bear in the head,
you got to shoot him in the fucking head.
You got to wait to the absolute last second.
I'm talking about urinating down both sides of your pant leg.
Just standing there like,
ah,
and just waiting so you can almost feel his breath and you better have a fucking
50 caliber and you just fire that fucker.
Um,
hundred yards away.
Fuck that.
Oh my God.
And you know,
you can fill the earth shaking.
Is that things coming at you?
I mean,
I'm just telling you,
you're,
that's just come.
All organs fail at that point.
Uh,
fuck that.
US rabid dogs.
Fuck yeah,
absolutely.
With the sword.
The great thing about a sword is that gives me a little bit of distance.
All right,
how do I meet these rabid dogs and my lowered into a pit?
Is this CME?
Are they running at me?
Fall three are running at me.
I there and right as they say,
the first one starts to leap.
I do a little sidestep little sachet,
a few will and I fucking just come right down.
Um,
whatever,
whatever meat I can hit.
And at that,
what I'm gonna do is I'm actually going to alligator arm it because the last
thing I want to have happen is for that sword to get stuck and that things flesh
as the other to take.
Take it.
Oh,
I'm really getting into this.
I'd fucking give him a nice fucking right there,
Fred.
Right little chop to him sent him to the side than the other fuckers.
Even if one of them's bite me,
my move is I'm hacking you leg.
I'm hacking you fucking done.
And the people right now like,
oh my God,
I love dog.
Shut up.
It's hypothetical and they're rabid.
They gotta be put down anyways and they're trying to kill me.
Oh,
Billy red face.
Who the woo fuck side you on here.
So that,
that would be my big move.
That would be my,
my big move.
Like I've always thought if I was ever hiking in somebody's eye,
I came upon somebody getting mauled by a,
a a mountain lion.
If ever I was actually,
I mean,
I mean I know what I would do in real life.
I'd be like,
well sucks for him.
Didn't see that.
Sorry.
What am I supposed to do?
Getting mauled too so I can get on the news.
Fuck that.
Um,
but if for some reason it was somebody I gave a shit about and they were going
to die,
I would,
I would run like a native American Ppp,
PPP really fucking softly and I would leap in the air and I would fucking Matt
Cook that Mountain Lion,
one of his back legs.
I would just fucking land on its leg and try to blow out,
you know,
and it's,
and it's lateral fucking movement and it would just fucking,
you know,
the great thing about wild animals or anything about animals in general is they
don't have a fucking ego.
Okay.
So they just kinda like,
you know,
when something like that happens,
they're just like,
okay,
I need to go lay down and heal even though that's not going to fucking heel.
That's uh,
that's,
I dunno.
So whatever,
that's,
that's how I would take the three dogs.
I would give a nice jab with the sword to the first one that came to me.
I take the bite of the second one,
I'd hack the leg of the third one,
and then I fucking start finishing them off.
That's what I would do.
And then I would go to the hospital,
uh,
with all three carcasses and I would say,
yeah,
I got bit by two out of three of these.
They're all fucking rabid.
And,
uh,
go ahead,
stick those needles in my stomach.
Let's get it over with and chain me to the radiator.
Let's see if Ocho mad or something,
you know?
Shit.
All right.
I liked the dilemmas.
Let's bring the dilemmas back.
I also liked youtube videos of the week.
I was a lot of,
there was a lot of fucking things out there.
Ah,
I remember.
Back then we used to have topics.
All right.
Corporate bullies,
they're built.
I used to be a bully.
Not a terrible one,
but the harmless Eddie Haskell type.
MMM.
All right.
See you more.
Just,
you would just like a,
just an asshole.
All right.
Harmless as I may have been.
I'm sure I heard some feelings.
It made some experiences less fun for those at the other end.
My question to you is,
how can I make this right?
Um,
I know I can't trace down the kids I grew up with,
but I see people being dicks and corporate America and want to call them out
without losing my job.
Do I tease them in the same style we did as children or take a serious route and
give it Denzel speech or at first of all,
why can't you track,
track down the kids you grew up with?
It happens all the time on Facebook,
of which you can find a lot of them.
You can go to a high school reunion.
MMM.
You could do it that way.
I think that would be a great thing to make you feel better and say,
Hey,
I'm an adult now.
I shouldn't have done that.
Sorry that I,
uh,
I dumped your books and gave you a fucking Wedgie.
Whatever the fuck you did.
Um,
I don't know how that works in corporate America.
I wouldn't give a Denzel speech,
uh,
that those speeches only work in the movies.
Um,
do I tease them in the same style we did his children?
Well,
you know what,
you need to elaborate.
They're bullying people.
Um,
I don't know.
You know,
in the job place,
if somebody is getting bullied,
that's really just on them,
you know,
and the,
and just the amount of shit that they've decided that they want to take in life.
You know,
it'd be one thing,
you know,
if someone was like,
putting his secretary and I and a headlock and was given her nuggies.
You know what I mean?
There was a bunch of fucking former athletes beaten on some form of Mathlete,
you know,
hanging outside his cubicle,
Wayne from to go over to the water bubbler,
they push him in a broom closet and fucking rough him up.
Yeah.
Then you got to do some.
But if it's just like mental torture,
mmm.
What I would do is I would walk up to the person getting bullied when he get a
chance and just say,
listen man,
you've got to stick up for yourself.
Stop taking that shit.
What's the Guy gonna do?
Throw his cuff links at you.
What are you afraid of?
Fuck him.
MMM.
But I know in the work environment you can't say,
Hey,
fuck you.
You have to come more.
You have to sit down.
Just say,
can I talk to you for a second?
And then they'll listen to you and then you gotta be like,
man,
listen,
I just noticed you've been a,
you know,
coming at me in a manner that,
that sort of indicates to me that you're not pleased with something about me.
And I was just wondering what that was,
you know?
And just leave it at that and see what that is.
And then,
you know,
if they want to sit there and try and make your life miserable at that point.
Um,
I,
cause I know there's all that passive aggressive horse shit that goes on in an
office.
Um,
but I have not,
fortunately never worked in that arena.
Tell you what,
you know what?
I need a little help on this one.
Everybody.
Um,
can you guys write in some that really corporate bullies things?
Can you write in a some passive aggressive shit that's been happening like they
do,
they want you to quit so they keep doing stuff to you.
You guys got any stories out there?
I think those are interesting.
I think those would help me fill up a fucking hour here on the blog.
All right,
so yeah,
I would go to a high school union.
I go to eyes grew union.
I think it'd be weird to reach out to somebody on Facebook,
hey,
sorry for being a dick.
Go to a high school reunion,
say to their face,
you know,
I would do that.
I wouldn't reach out on Facebook.
Facebook is,
this should just fucking a weird,
um,
anyways.
All right,
kid,
kid movies.
Uh,
dear Billy,
the kid lists.
Oh,
just when you think there's not an original one left.
That's a fucking great one.
He said,
I'm a father of two little girls.
Congratulations.
Um,
all my free time is spent with them and there's a lot of kids programming is
happening in my life.
I was wondering the other day,
does bill like any kid movies,
classics,
like the Goonies or Disney animation?
Don't worry.
Even if you don't like any now you will enjoy them when your own child is
getting all giggly and bubbly over the site of a little mermaid.
Um,
of course I do.
I mean,
I didn't the Goonies and was too old when that came out.
I was already a teenager,
so I was watching more quality cinema,
like young blood and a roadhouse.
Um,
okay.
Let me see here.
What do I,
oh yeah,
like all the Disney stuff.
MMM.
I never liked Mickey mouse's voice,
so I liked goofy.
I liked Pluto.
Donald Duck was fucking hilarious.
Why do they always make the duck be the Dick,
you know?
Did Warner Brothers rip off Donald Duck with Daffy Duck?
I hate and I hated daffy duck by the way.
I couldn't stand that fucking dude.
And after a while I didn't like bugs bunny either.
Bugs bunny always one.
So he was fucking annoying and Daffy duck was just kind of this piece of Shit,
you know?
Okay.
Hst,
you know,
he just would do shit the fuck up cell phone.
You're not flying south for the winter and now I'm supposed to feel bad for you.
You did up.
I gotta give you another bath.
What's wrong with you?
Do you need a flea treatment?
They have clean audio.
Huh?
You know what's funny about her when she's anticipating me either saying if she
wants to know she's already,
I can't even say one,
go to a plate basically outside or go for a ride.
Her ears.
She's staring at me right now.
Park up.
They,
she looks like bat ears or her eyes.
She just locks in on me.
The psycho pit bull look,
ears come up and she just stares at me with all census.
Like did he just say what I said?
I thought he said I would actually get a riled up.
But it's a main thing to do.
You want me to do it?
Fine.
I'll do it.
You want to hear her?
How she does this every once in a while,
cleo.
Okay.
Cleo,
do you want to go for a ride?
Huh?
Cleo.
Cleo?
Yeah.
Do you
all right,
we'll go on a second.
We'll go on a second.
Go lay down.
Sorry.
Got You all excited.
You know what I just did?
I just did like knows fail when videos.
I put the hot chick in the beginning,
didn't I?
I'm sorry buddy.
Go girl will go in a minute.
Um,
whew.
Okay.
Um,
yeah,
I like,
um,
I didn't like the Little Mermaid.
I'm not into fish.
Women.
It's just fucking weird.
And then there's always some sort of like,
the guy ends up fucking,
the fish woman has this.
It's fucking creepy.
Like splash,
you know?
I mean,
this is really crude,
but you just always think,
you know,
you just think the downstairs is going to be a little ripe,
if you know what I mean.
How do you tell?
Do you look in her eye for eyes?
Cloudy.
You don't go down there.
Oh Jesus.
That's a fish joke everybody.
Now that's how you pick out fresh fish.
Hey,
you know what?
I actually looked up this recipe.
This is my favorite thing on youtube.
It's for garlic,
garlic,
mashed potatoes.
And this is how the guy,
the way the guy ends,
this video is so fucking priceless.
Um,
yeah.
Let me see if I can bring this up.
This has been,
this is the youtube video of the week.
Ah,
Jesus with the advertising.
Don't they know everybody hits fucking mute and then scrolls down and you just
look at the yellow bar.
That's what I do.
Eight more seconds.
Six more seconds.
Three,
two,
one pant.
All right,
so basically this guy make potatoes are delicious side.
There's the parallel with the meats.
Poultry.
I just want you to hear this.
Well,
whoa.
Shut up.
All right,
here we go.
So he basically just said,
shut up to a video.
That's how dumb I am.
Um,
he basically makes these garlic mashed potatoes.
He known the end.
Then they got to try it and tell you how fucking delicious it is.
Yeah,
this is it,
right?
Hey,
listen to what this guy says.
This is this fucking,
this made my week.
Here we go.
Recipe.
You'll be glad you [inaudible].
Thanks for 2 billion,
man.
That's
such fucking guy.
You could not get mad at that guy.
I played that for Nia right before we went to bed last night and she fought.
She almost fell out of the bed laughing.
He goes,
thanks for Youtube.
And he goes,
that's garlic mashed potatoes.
Thanks for Youtube and see next time.
And then he puts the garlic mashed potatoes,
his mouth.
He just goes,
yeah,
it's good.
Okay.
Uh,
you know what,
in his videos will get better because I've actually seen outtakes where he's
actually more relaxed,
more like who he is.
He's just been doing them.
I don't know what's this from a few years ago or whatever.
I always believe that people are going to get better.
All right,
so here we go.
Why have we got one more read here?
All right,
first time dear Billy,
go lucky.
I'm going to lose my V card next weekend.
Jesus Christ.
I always,
that always surprises me when people know when they're going to lose their
virginity.
Doesn't just happen like it did for me.
You know,
like it's never going to happen.
And then somebody just grabbed your Dick and you allow shit.
Here we go.
Whoo.
And you drive it home.
I didn't know people planned it.
Right?
I'm like,
I just said somebody just grabbed your Dick.
Like it could be anybody from like some fucking 60 year old man.
Gross.
Um,
what was I going to say?
Like you guys actually plan this shit out.
It's going down next Sunday.
I'm going to lose my V card next weekend.
Me and the girl are corny.
High School love birds and it couldn't be more right.
I think I know the answer to this question,
but I'll ask you anyways.
Should I pull it in her face now?
Now,
should I blow it in her face to commemorate the occasion?
Then he says,
kidding.
Real question.
Should I think about mixing up positions or just keep it ida?
I love making,
um,
yeah,
I,
uh,
I gotta be honest with you.
I,
I never,
I never hooked up with the Virgin.
Okay.
The woman,
it was a woman,
she was a hormone that and,
and she had been around the block.
All right,
so there was no,
uh,
yeah,
I don't know.
I didn't have that experience.
I would probably say the first time you do it,
you don't want to flip her over.
Um,
yeah,
this is a big responsibility.
I would try to keep it as loving and as Nice as you can.
And,
uh,
I would probably do that the first half dozen to a dozen times and then,
you know,
let it get comfortable there buddy,
before you start fucking trying to,
you know what it is about your kids is the amount of porn you've probably
watched the access that you have to it.
You know,
I wonder if,
if,
if kids,
I,
that's a fucking creepy thought.
Sorry.
Strike that when,
if I shouldn't even say kids.
Teenagers of age.
Yeah.
I mean they gotta be better at it than we were.
We had no idea.
All you had was rumors when I was a kid.
You didn't know what the fuck you were doing.
You had to figure it out because you just walked into the bush.
Okay.
No fucking trail.
No nothing.
You guys are while you guys are walking right down the open highway.
Okay.
Just to do something.
I didn't even
the thought of blown it and in some woman's face like I didn't even,
you didn't even think Google even thought I shit like that.
Okay.
I'm,
I'm trying to think when the facial came arrived there,
when I was in high school,
like the two pornos I think I ever saw.
Yeah.
The big thing was when the VCR came out and then all of a sudden,
you know,
and then it was somebody who had to have the balls to go into,
do those fucking saloon doors at the back of the video shop.
And you just fucking went in there.
Huh?
He just grab one really quick.
What'd you get?
I don't know.
It had tents and then you fucking went out like,
okay,
nobody did that.
Right?
Nobody fucking down.
I'm trying to think.
The first time I even saw that first time I saw it,
I thought it was fucking gross.
Like a lot of porn.
You're like,
oh my God,
that's disgusting.
And then you're like,
oh my God,
that's the only thing that gets me off.
Then you move to the next level,
which is the danger report.
Right?
You just keep going further and further down the fucking a,
and next thing you know,
you could work on a vice squad without getting sick while you're eating a
fucking man.
A sandwich over there.
Sorry,
this is getting gross.
But it's true.
And if elected no child under the age of 18,
you will be allowed to watch somebody bust it in somebody's face.
Ask Not who's face.
You can bust it.
Ed.
Um,
yeah.
Wow.
Jesus.
I mean,
even like your question,
like how fucking uh,
advanced you already are if you never fucking did anything.
Cause when I,
like I said,
there was no video.
We had no game film when I was a kid.
Did,
you guys can sit there and go over and over and over like fucking bill Belicheck
we had no,
there was no game film.
And then because there was so little information you had to act like you knew
everything and several would bring something up and you,
and you'd be sitting there on the outside,
just total fucking world series of poker face.
And on the inside you're panicking going,
what the fuck are they talking about?
What is that?
I don't know what that is.
You know,
and I don't know if my dad knows what it is,
but I'm certainly not talking about it up to him because that's fucking gross.
Just talking to him about it would be fucking gross in,
in a whole other levels.
He doing that to my mom.
I have fucked.
Does he know that?
Right?
So
I dunno.
So like I said,
just keep it,
I love making,
I would leave it at that.
All right.
And with that,
everybody,
that is the Monday morning podcast here for Memorial Day.
All right,
thank you to all the troops.
Anybody who's ever served,
uh,
for giving me the wonderful life that I have,
protecting my life and on,
and it means a lot more to me now that I actually,
you know,
got that chance to go over there to Omaha beach and everything added a whole
nother level of reality to it.
So,
uh,
that is it.
So thank you to all the troops.
The rest of you guys go fuck yourself.
So I'll talk to you next week.
Get your solar panels,
get your idea patented,
and if you're making love to a virgin this week,
so let's try to keep it idi hung guys.
All right.
See you.